aachen 23 uhr zwei junge leute unterwegs
um lebensmittel in mülltonnen zu suchen
sie nennen es containern
containern bedeutet das nicht zu
akzeptieren dass diese lebensmittel in
den tonnen von supermärkten liegen
bleiben sondern ich gehe dann 18 und
holt wieder raus
seit zehn jahren macht christian walther
das schon so er sammelt alles ein was
luftdicht verpackt ist der rest kommt
wieder zurück in den müll
da haben wir tourist board reduziert
und nochmal das gleiche hier kleiner
sandwich voßwinkel
vertragen nach halbe tonne poller brotes
bestimmt wenn man die anderen sachen
rausholt supermärkte haben oft diese
selbstbedienungs station wo auf
gebackene backwaren angeboten werden und
die sind ja oft auch noch relativ gut
gefüllte man kurz vor der anschluss
daran geht und das verändert alles
danach in die mülltonnen das ist völlig
klar da sind man vor welcher komplett
voll mit brot oder anderen backwaren
pizza süßkram man sieht wie viel
weggeworfen wird
also das containern ist leider nicht
erlaubt das ist tatsächlich in
deutschland nicht straftat das ist ein
diebstahl vorsicht hier sind scherben
drin das ein skandal dass das
lebensmittel retten verboten ist und
dass das lebensmittel wegwerfen legal
ist und deswegen ist es für mich legitim
und das ist mir für mich wichtiger als
die rechtliche situation
allein aus privaten haushalten landen
schätzungsweise pro kopf und jahr 75
kilogramm lebensmittelabfälle im müll
zirka 14 prozent davon sind brot und
backwaren
eine brotfabrik bei hamburg harry brot
ist marktführer in deutschland
umsatz 2020 mehr als eine milliarde euro
doch wo viel verkauft wird wird auch
viel weggeworfen
also erstmal ganz wichtig zu sagen wir
haben uns schon in den letzten zehn
zwölf jahren halbiert unser brot was wir
retourniert zurückbekommen vom händler
wird ja weiter verwertet für die
futtermittelindustrie
aber diese anteile sind über die jahre
extrem zurückgegangen wenn wir gut
disponieren ja und mit dem händler heute
nennt man das ja forecasting neudeutsch
also eine gute gemeinsame planung machen
und absatz gerecht disponieren können
dann machen wir alles richtig auch zum
thema lebensmittelverschwendung
doch wie kann es sein dass trotzdem so
viel essen in mülltonnen landet sicher
ist es gibt kaum konkrete daten wer
wieviel wegwirft es gibt keine
verbindlichen regeln für bäckereien oder
auch für andere lebensmittel hersteller
gaz sie gucken müssen was geht
eigentlich wirklich verloren es wird
einfach nur geschätzt und das hat zur
folge dass man natürlich auch nicht
erkennt wo die eigentliche problematik
liegt dann muss man überlegen was könnte
man unter umständen daran ändern dass
das in der zeile in dem ausmaße nicht
mehr passiert oder gar nicht mehr und
das müsste auch verpflichtend sein das
kann nicht alles auf freiwilliger basis
sein weil wir sehen seit neun jahren
passiert ganz wenig ich glaube das wäre
der falsche weg jetzt hier auf den
gesetzgeber zu setzen an der stelle und
wir sehen da keine notwendigkeit von
gesetzesanpassung dabei ist der politik
schon lange klar es muss etwas passieren
2012 große ziele aber alles freiwillig
die europäische kommission hat die
zielmarke ausgegeben bis 2020 eu-weit
die mimik mit die menge der unnötig
weggeworfenen lebensmittel um 50 prozent
zu verringern das haben wir noch einen
grandios verpasst und dann muss jetzt
endlich genügend druck aufgebaut werden
damit man sich hinsetzt und ernsthaft
darüber nachdenken dinge geändert werden
wenn man bedenkt dass etwa ein drittel
aller lebensmittel ungenutzt im müll
landen ist es natürlich ein drittel
aller agrarflächen auch und auf diesen
flächen kann da nichts anderes angebaut
werden das hat natürlich auch zur folge
dass wir unseren planeten über nutzen
immer wieder hat die bundesregierung
angekündigt mehr zu tun gegen das
massenhafte lebensmittel wegwerfen
2009 10 erneut große versprechen wieder
alles freiwillig heute habe ich im
kabinett unsere strategie die wir im
koalitionsvertrag
verabredet hatten zur reduktion von
lebensmittelabfällen vorgestellt wir
werden bis 2030 die
lebensmittelverschwendung halbieren wenn
man aber sieht was tatsächlich passiert
habe ich große zweifel daran dass das
auf diesem wege bis 2030 erreicht wird
köln hier will christian horsters nicht
länger warten er rettet brot und
brötchen auf eigene faust
bei diesem becker kommen jeden tag
zurück 700 brote etwa
1500 süße teile und 12 bis 15 1000
brötchen
und da dürfen wir alles retten was
retour kommt was wir aber auch nur
andeutungsweise schaffen das sind
zweieinhalb tonnen beste backwaren
entweder gehen die zu uns wir lernen
denen unsere körper oder säcke das geht
in den container ein und da wird dann
tierfutter drauf gemacht aber was unterm
strich heißt es wird sehr entwertet
[Musik]
foster's hat vor etwa zwei jahren den
verein food for future köln gegründet
jeder kann vorbeikommen und sich etwas
zu essen holen ohne bedingungen
wobei es mir hauptsächlich im um die
backwaren geht bei die backwaren die wir
hier nicht retten die gehen verloren ich
komme da nicht drauf klar also dass
treiben auch immer wieder die tränen in
die augen weil das fühlt sich so völlig
falsch und dann nebenan bei diese dinge
die sind zu 100 prozent gut
[Musik]